good morning Hank it's Tuesday welcome
very early inaudible a few weeks ago and
began a long drive south slums at the
edge of the city gave way to beautiful
vistas and then the road worsened and I
became a bobble head until at last we
reached a rural health care center so
Hank here's a story I heard a lot in
Ethiopia traditionally Ethiopian women
haven't named their children for several
months after they were born because the
risk of losing the babies was just too
high but lately thanks for the
astonishing drop in mortality rates due
to smart aid and good government
investment Ethiopian women have begun to
name their babies at birth it's a great
story and it's one that tugs at the
heartstrings and makes you want to open
your wallet it's also well the truth
turns out to be maybe less narrative ly
interesting but in a way more
encouraging so the Ethiopian healthcare
system is organized into tiers you begin
with hospitals but with more than 80% of
people living in rural areas the next
level
the health care center is vital here
there are lots of medications and
vaccines there's a lab technician who
can diagnose parasites and operate the
centrifuge some health care centers even
perform c-sections all this despite the
fact that almost none of them have
running water when I asked center
manager Abdul Qadeer what he needed most
he answered immediately water while we
were there I also met Bill Gates the
founder of Microsoft and sued Desmond
Hellman the CEO of the Gates Foundation
to be honest with you Hank I kind of
assumed that bill and sue were visiting
Ethiopia for like a photo op but yeah no
they were there to ask questions and
lots of them to ask how the lab tech
typed malaria with that particular
microscope which vaccines were stored in
what quantities how many workers were
needed to run the center efficiently and
so on and watching villains who
gravitate away from cameras and toward
health workers it became clear to me
that the Gates Foundation is fundamental
principle that all human lives have
equal value isn't just rhetoric so then
I traveled to the next healthcare tier
the outpost where health extension
workers like Utah gisu with the 10th
grade education and a year of training
provide basic care in rural areas they
taught us who showed me her well
organized medical records the delivery
room in which many babies are born and
wall charts measuring vaccination rates
but mostly she and her co-workers were
busy taking care of people like this
little boy was being tested for malaria
with a pinprick test that has
dramatically improved diagnosis and
treatment when he was found to be
positive the health extension workers
could begin treatment immediately this
little guide was extremely sick with
diarrhea that was suspected to be a
virus diarrhea remains one of the
leading causes of child death in
Ethiopia even though it is almost always
survivable if
can stay hydrated so this boy went home
with a rehydration solution that might
well have saved his life and then there
is one last year of the Ethiopian
healthcare system the women's health
army my favorite army of all time these
are female volunteers who take maternal
and infant care into their communities
talking about everything from family
planning to how to get folic acid a
member of the health army invited me
into her home and showed me the map that
she uses to keep track of who's sick
who's pregnant and who has a small child
and this is how with limited resources
information and care travels the last
few miles into rural communities I think
I don't want to minimize the amazing
work that the Gates Foundation and other
organizations are doing in Ethiopia or
the importance of technologies like the
easy to read malaria test or this
amazing thermos that keeps vaccines cold
for 50 days without electricity but the
real heroes of Ethiopia's health
successes are Ethiopian the women
volunteering in their communities health
extension workers treating disease and
compiling data mothers fighting to keep
their kids healthy despite the immense
challenges of poverty their progress has
been real and should be celebrated but
there's also much to do kids should not
die of diarrhea or pneumonia or malaria
and far too many still do so about that
naming at Birth thing I asked these
women about it and they all agreed that
kids do get named at birth now which
never used to happen some said that it
might be because child mortality is
lower these days but most felt that it
was because now they have to fill out
birth certificates that doesn't tug on
the heartstrings in quite the same way
but in the end it's maybe an even better
sign because good health records are
vital to good health care in short Hank
when it comes to health care
heartwarming narratives and boring
bureaucracy are not always mutually
exclusive anyway then I rode in a
helicopter with Bill Gates which was
terrifying in hilarious and I will
definitely tell you about it next week
unless I get meningitis again or
something hank dftba I will see you on
Friday